[Music]
i wanted to make a video to just say
thank you
first of all because i'm genuinely
thankful for everyone supporting the
channel this year
i think it's been a great year for me
and i feel like it's not allowed to say
that can i
am i allowed to say that i had fun i
don't know
no it was terrible i hated it okay sorry
okay how was your year
was it good okay cool
well let me ask you another question
actually what do you think about new
year's resolutions
be honest yeah see i used to really
criticize
the new year's resolutions i thought
they never work it's dumb
and you see it every time if you go to
the gym there's just this
wave of zombies
passing through and then they disappear
just as quick as they came
it's so bizarre but i thought two years
ago
i think was it three how much time i
passed i don't know
i set a new year's resolution for myself
that actually really worked and helped
me
so much which was the goal to read if i
pick up
something whatever it is i should
actually finish it because it's so easy
to just keep
starting new things instead of going
through that difficult period and
actually finish it
the problem with that is that you rob
yourself from the
reward of actually that sensation of yes
i did this this is great i
completed something uh and that worked
out really well for me
so it's not just about changing stuff in
your life for a short period
of time or when it gets hard or
difficult you stop or
if you look at the end goal it seems too
far away the difference is that
you set goals for yourself because you
do it for you and no one else and for no
other reason and
that you then recognize okay i've
started these habits
and they're they're good for me so i'm
going to keep doing them forever
because why not and there's something
really empowering about that making that
choice at least for me and i
i made that choice about working out
which has been really
just done me so much good i it really
clears your head
uh to have a regular exercise in your
life a lot of times i have a really
stupid day
and uh sorry for rambling so much but i
have a point
and you just feel great you're like oh
life isn't so bad after all how about
that
i feel good now so i wanted to
share these new habits that i've had in
my life and
spread them to you guys because it's
been really positive for me and
i want you guys to feel good too yeah i
don't know if this works for everyone
i realize that i'm a very routine based
person so it probably won't work for
everyone but if you feel up for it and
you want to try it
let's do it so here's what we're going
to do all right
we'll start with workout right i would
recommend to set a goal for yourself
okay this year i'm going to work out and
it can be small too okay i'm gonna work
out once a week
right that's better than nothing or even
better
i'm gonna work out three times a week
this month anyone can do something for a
month right
set those goals okay i'm gonna do it
monday wednesday friday and i'm gonna do
it
no matter what even if i'm busy that day
and no excuses you just do it if you
wanna if you haven't set a goal for
yourself
you put that first and you make sure you
do it okay
that's just how it is i don't know it
works for me at least
five times a week [ __ ] i don't know
that's what i do i used to do six times
a week and i found that a bit too much
and that's just kind of thing just find
whatever works for you and what you
you like about it if you can't go to a
gym that's fine
you can work out from home no big deal
there's a ton of youtube videos or and
youtube channels that
tell you how to do this sort of workouts
check it out
find what you like and what works for
you but set the goals to do it
certain times a day of the week do it
for 30 days
re-evaluate what you're doing and and
think okay this is something good for me
have i gotten something good positive
out of this if yes
keep going i'm gonna do it forever why
not there's nothing bad about it
i mean the greeks figured this out
literally thousands of years ago they
knew
that instilling how habitual creatures
we are and that instilling
good habits in our life means living a
virtuous life it's epic
speaking of the ancient greeks second
thing if you want to join me as well
is i'm going to bring back book club
yeah book review
that's what it's called a i used to read
at least 50 pages a day
when i did it the most and i i loved it
so much i kind of
toned back a little bit which i really
regret so i want to go back to that
so therefore i'm bringing back book
review if you want to join me
same principle is working out set a goal
for yourself
you don't have to pick the same book i
do i recognize that not everyone is
going to care about these things
i like reading just pick something that
interests you but if you pick the book
you have to finish it all right no
matter what so you can set a goal
okay i'm going to read 10 pages a day or
20 pages a day or 30 whatever 100
i don't know but it's good to pick a
goal it really helps
one of the books or the main book i'm
gonna review is
discourses and selected writings by epic
titus
it's really really good it's about the
philosophy of stoicism
it's pretty straightforward as well so
it's not too difficult i think
i don't know and i'll be reviewing it
with other books
at the end of january yeah it's 400
pages
so that means you have to read 13
and a third page a day what would that
be that's like 20 minutes of reading max
right nothing 20 minute a day anyone can
do something
20 minutes a day come on do it for 30
days
check it out realize is this good for me
is it bad for me did i get something out
of this did i not and then keep going
you will keep going come on let's do
this
i don't want to become like a [ __ ]
inspirational channel or something this
is literally just stuff
that i like it helped me and i want i
want you guys to get the same habits
you can get so much out of two simple
things which is reading and working out
really
those two things are the best things
i've incorporated in my
my daily life um that i'm really happy
about so
let's do it and if not fine whatever who
cares i don't know
but yeah again huge thank you for
everyone for supporting the channel i
really appreciate it
i think this year i've i also want to
make clear that i
i think i've become a little harsher on
you guys
i've i've really become tired of a lot
of [ __ ] online and i
i'm done tolerating it so a lot of times
if i see bad stuff online i
i go back uh at you guys a little bit
sometimes
i just want you to take it personally
all right and i'm not speaking at
everyone i still really really
appreciate my audience and
i really really like you guys as well
yo you made me say it ill just don't
want it to be misunderstood
okay that's it let's make 2021
a great year join me
see you next year bros oh it's
it's older than next year i just
realized um well you better get started